en janvier 1944 les forces alliées
engagée en italie était aux prises avec
l'impressionnante artillerie lourde
allemande
les énormes obus explosifs étaient tirés
par deux canons monté sur rail est
positionné à plus de 48 kilomètres de là
les troupes alliées à l'autre bout de la
courbe balistique de ces obus avaient
surnommés ces deux armes monstrueuse
anzuoni et hangzhou express
les deux canons allemands étaient les
cas 5 / wagons qui à l'origine avait été
envoyé en italie à destination de
l'afrika korps en tunisie la campagne
tunisienne s'étant terminées avant
qu'ils étaient et livrés les deux
monstrueux canon furent déployés en
italie le canon k5 était considéré comme
l'un des canons sur rails les plus
aboutis de son époque
il en fit la preuve en italie
l'artillerie du troisième reich un
extraordinaire arsenal
voici un canon sur wright cassin il est
baptisé léopold lors de la campagne d'en
diot il fut également connu sous le
surnom de johannie il tirait un
projectile de 236 kg à 50 km de distance
avec une très grande précision
il avait un jumeau baptisé d'or fille
durant la campagne de france la fin de
la campagne
les deux canons étaient déployés sur la
côte près de calais bombardait la grande
bretagne depuis la france
le premier cas 5 entré en service en
1936 et la production continuera
jusqu'en 1945
le nombre d'exemplaires produits reste
incertain mais on suppose qu'il oscille
entre 25 et 28
sous presque tous les angles le k5 était
une machinerie minutieuse avec un
excellent équipements de chargement des
munitions et un long et fin canon qui
lui donna son surnom allemand de schalke
bertha housse felt bertha toutes les
heures le k 5 e pouvait tirer huit obus
de 11 pouces 279,4 mm pesant
approximativement 113 kg à plus de 60 km
mais cette énorme puissance de feu
nécessité une imposante chaîne
logistique avec sa propre drame
ferroviaire
à côté de ce qu'annonce spécialement
conçu pour l'asphalté bertha elle-même
le train incluait un wagon de munitions
un wagon pour l'équipage
plusieurs wagons de soutien et bien sûr
une locomotive pour tracter l'ensemble
alors que la guerre avant c'est que la
luftwaffe perdait le contrôle des cieux
des wagons de défense antiaérienne
furent ajoutés au train pour fournir une
protection contre les avions ennemis
tenter par cette cible de choix
chargé le canon pour le tir était une
opération longue et laborieuse
il fallait d'abord abaisser le canon à
l'horizontale puis faire circuler les
obus le long d'un couloir d'alimentation
depuis le wagon à munitions une fois en
place sur le couloir d'alimentation
les obus étaient poussés mécaniquement
dans la chambre les charges propulsives
était ensuite ajouté la chambre était
alors verrouillé
l'officier de tir qui déterminait la
taille des charges en fonction de la
distance et de la météo
règle l élévation et l'azimut une fois
cette tâche accomplie le tube été
relevés et l'équipage rejoignait ses
positions pour le tir
le tireur habituellement un
sous-officier supérieur appuyez sur le
bouton qui mettait à feu électriquement
le canon la détonation faisait trembler
les vitres à un kilomètre 5 à la ronde
une fois que le but quittait le tube un
observateur d'artillerie positionnées 55
kilomètres plus loin près de la cible
observait le résultat du tir et envoyait
par radio les corrections éventuelles à
l'officier de tir de nouveaux réglages
étaient calculées et la procédure toute
entière se reproduisait
elle use of very difficult un complexe
size amener un canon sur rail en
opération était une opération complexe
et très difficile dans les conditions
tactiles telles que celles existant près
des plages de débarquement dans ces cas
n'en furent conçues pour les sièges ce
qui en l'occurrence c'était le cas en
réalité il était surtout utilisé pour
des tirs de saturation de toute évidence
les tireurs ne pouvait voir car ils
étaient trop loin
comment les obus toucher leur cible il
avait donc besoin d'un observateur
avancé jet de la plage ni des doses on
observe qu'ils puissent les renseigner
sur l'impact des obus et leur indiquer
par radio les corrections nécessaires
pour ajuster leurs tirs en conséquence
les deux canons qui devinrent connu sous
les noms d'anthony et en duo express
furent envoyés au sud de la zone banzio
via rome fin janvier 1944 trouver une
position pour les canons et leur train
était la première priorité la position
choisie était situé près d'albano sur la
rive ferroviaire entre rome et net ou
non juste avant dans un tunnel
l' avantage de cette position était que
le cas 5e pouvait être mis à couvert
dans le tunnel sortir pour se mettre en
position de tir et être aussitôt remis à
couvert après avoir tiré son énorme au
but le tir des canons étaient si
régulier que les troupes alliées supposé
immédiatement qu'ils avaient affaire à
un seul tube bien que les deux canons
fussent réellement en action les obus
étaient si grands les explosifs étaient
vraiment énorme
ce qui ne l'avait pas besoin de causer
de pertes humaines pour atteindre le
moral de lehman coach et bien sûr quand
il donnait atteindre une cible ils
causaient des dégâts considérables
l'un des avantages majeurs de ces canons
sur règne en italie concernaient la
propagande new jersey l'actualité
allemande de cette période pouvait
montrer ses canons et les utiliser pour
remonter le moral de la population
allemande
le public voyant ces images dans les
cinémas penser que leurs troupeaux
maîtrisait la situation
évidemment ils eurent un gros impact sur
les alliés qui pensaient avoir affaire à
un seul en duo a ni le nom lui est resté
pendant quarante cinquante ans en est
faite
pendant quatre ans les deux canaux
menèrent la vie dure aux soldats alliés
déployés dans la zone dans dieu
inconstant déluge de feu fut déverser
dans les trois zones des plages du
débarquement en conjonction avec les
deux canons d'autres bombardements
d'artillerie plus légères ajoutait à
l'adversité ils rendirent cette tête de
pont infernale à tenir pour les soldats
alliés il y avait beaucoup de tirs
d'artillerie efficace qui arrivait sur
les plages dans john challenger
toutefois le gros des tirs d'artillerie
qui atterrissait sur les plages dans
l'audio venait de cas non moins
impressionnant de l'artillerie lourde
allemande
ce n'était pas tant les munitions dans
do you and i en duo exprès mais les obus
plus petit de 210 mm heureusement les
canons sur rail était à l'origine de
l'enfer quotidien que vivaient les
soldats britanniques et américains
déployés à un monsieur d c'était aussi
l'artillerie de 170 mm plus modeste que
les allemands avaient regroupé autour de
la plage route et qu'ils pouvaient tirer
assez rapidement beaucoup de but
l'aviation alliée fille ce qu'elle pût
pour trouver et détruire les sites de
tir des cas 5
bien que la rfm réussi à identifier avec
précision les positions de tir la zone
de tir était bien camouflés et les
canons étaient toujours garder à
l'intérieur du tunnel chaque fois que
les avions alliés approchait la campagne
dans diot cette arme manoeuvre est
dedans et en dehors du tunnel
dès que l'aviation alliée n'était plus
dans les parages le canon était tracté à
l'extérieur du tunnel
il tirait et l'obuts arrivé comme un
train express sur les plages de rio
c'est pourquoi les troupes l'appelèrent
en bio express la lourde procédure de
mise en batterie de préparation pour le
tir du tir lui même des ajustements
ultérieurs était un exercice compliqué
il était très difficile de maintenir une
bonne précision pour conserver chez
l'efficacité du bombardement
d'artillerie
en action le canon causaient des dégâts
terribles ils restent à déployer jusqu'à
ce que les alliés père cela ligne gustav
mais après la chute de cassino en mars
1944 les alliés balayèrent alors le nord
pour soulager les plages mondiaux
ils accomplir une rapide manoeuvre vers
le nord n'ont pas le long du littoral
mais à l'intérieur des terres ceux qui
coupaient les lignes de chemin de fer
qui constituait la voix de repli des
canons sur rails
les canons furent capturés presque
intacte est prêt à faire mouvement
un canon fut endommagée par ses servants
avant d'être capturé mais l'autre fut
trouvé presque entier et cet exemplaire
fut ensuite envoyé aux etats-unis pour
être examinés et testés
il est toujours visible aux abords d'une
province grounds dans le maryland aux
états unis
l'artillerie régulier
la division standards de la wehrmacht
durant la seconde guerre mondiale
déployait des pièces d'artillerie plus
lourdes et plus nombreuses que celles de
ses adversaires sur le papier ont en
théorie une division d'infanterie
allemande entièrement équipée disposait
d'un régiment d'artillerie se pose en se
croyant
c'était une unité d'artillerie assez
imposantes comme l'était l'artillerie
allemande la ligne à quatre sous
division d'artillerie ce qui
représentait au début de la guerre une
force de 48 ans plus tard les unités fut
réduite à 42 canon par division le point
clé à garder à l'esprit qu'au cours de
la seconde guerre mondiale il y avait
une difficulté majeure pour garder
l'artillerie divisionnaire à sa taille
complète beaucoup de régiment
d'artillerie les missionnaires ne
disposait pas du nombre de cas non
prévus
la première arme à être fournis à
l'armée allemande après la première
guerre mondiale fut le light infantry
des chutes ce 18 de 75 mm
c'était une pièce d'équipement légère et
robuste de construction inhabituel le
canon était tenu dans un support
rectangulaire qui était lui-même fixé au
socle et aux systèmes de mise à feu
le mécanisme ressembler globalement à
celui d'un fusil à pompe et bien
qu'inhabituel il était simple et rapide
le châssis était une simple remorque
avec un blindage les roues étaient en
bois cerclées de fer pour la version
tirée par des chevaux où on dise que
dassier avec des pneus pour celles
tractée par camion
ces premiers canons furent utilisés de
manière intensive durant toute la guerre
mais leur emploi tandis à décliner vers
la fin du conflit la demande à l'envers
des armes de plus en plus grosse l'une
des solutions est elle oubliée de 105 mm
qui fut utilisé un grand nombre dans les
premières années de la guerre
initialement il donna à l'artillerie
divisionnaire allemande l'ascendant sur
quasiment tous ses adversaires dont la
plupart étaient armés l'équipement
obsolète datant de la grande guerre dont
les calibres ne dépassait pas le 75 mm
l'infanterie allemande de bénéficier de
l'appui des obusiers fh 18 de 105 mm
j'ai été tractés par des chevaux faudra
médecins des sauveteurs
armstrong à certains moments ils le
furent par les semis chenilles et
transports c'est pareil mais dans la
plupart des unités il était tiré par les
cheveux gris mauve steen soerensen trois
grandes divisions d'infanterie allemande
pouvait compter sur trois batteries
d'obusiers de 105 mm appuyé par une
batterie supplémentaire d'obusiers lourd
un homme à 250 mm et de canon de 100
millimes ftc aux 350
il y avait donc une bonne puissance de
feu pour les appuis mais en général le
maillon faible et l organisation de
l'espace aérien
la guerre se poursuivait et des
adversaires de plus en plus moderne à
savoir les canons de 25 livres 85 mm
britannique et le trompeur 76 mm
soviétique démontrèrent que les obusiers
de 105 mm pouvait en termes de portée
être dépasser sans difficulté par des
armes de calibre plus faibles les
événements de la campagne d'hiver russe
en 1941 1942 montrèrent les autres
défauts majeurs des canons allemands
le cycle du gel et du dégel pendant
l'hiver réduisait les routes de
ravitaillement du front de l'est à
l'état de bourbier ainsi les hobbies
également ne pouvait progresser que
lentement
beaucoup furent perdues durant cet hiver
1941-42 simplement parce qu'il reste est
pris dans la bouche de l'est pendant la
retraite et ne pouvait plus être
déplacés l'artillerie divisionnaire de
l'armée allemande
au début de la seconde guerre mondiale
était généralement hippomobile et se
déplacer au même rythme que les soldats
d'infanterie à pied un saut l'artillerie
divisionnaire n'était alors pas plus
mobiles que les soldats elle était
tracté lentement par des chevaux elle
dépend des de l'eau et de la nourriture
des chevaux plus que du pétrole
hormis certaines applications telles que
les divisions de montagne croit
l'artillerie divisionnaire était donc
assez lente au début de la guerre au
cours de la guerre devient nécessaire de
motoriser l'artillerie
c'est alors que l'artillerie
divisionnaire commence à être tracté tu
démarres des engins à moteur par
division les canons étaient généralement
tractées par des semis chenilles et de
grosses miches uni et darty
occasionnellement si on avait de la
chance qu'il pouvait s'agir des hummel
ou des vestes qui étaient des canons
automoteurs mais dans la plupart des cas
le standard principal des livres
allemande reste à tout au long de la
guerre la retire hippomobile
le problème ne se présenta pas
réellement en europe occidentale où il y
avait de bonnes routes comme en pologne
ou en france 30 pays dans lesquels la
résistance avait été limité et où tous
les combats avaient été livrés au
printemps ou au début de l'été vrai
problème apparu en russie car il n'y
avait pas de bonnes routes et
l'enchaînement des périodes de boules de
neige et de glace rendait le déplacement
infernale les canons s'enfonçait dans la
boue parfois au delà de leurs essieux
il fallait une grande force aux hommes
et aux chevaux pour les sortir de là
parfois ce n'était pas possible
si la bouge elle devenait dur comme de
la pierre info il n'était alors plus
possible de les bouger sans laquelle le
problème de la mobilité était donc
énorme en russie la ligne de front
pouvait se déplacer très vite de 25 km
et revenir aussi vite à son point de
départ
les hommes devaient couvrir de grandes
distances
au début de l'opération barbarossa par
exemple l'armée allemande avait engagé
en russie plus de 625 mieux vaut pour
traiter les cas nos stars et non aux
notes sur les routes cet interminable
corps de ressembler à un mastodonte
ambulants qui ralentissait la
progression des divisions d'infanterie
malgré son succès initial l'invasion de
l'union soviétique en 1941 révéla de
nombreuses faiblesses dans l'artillerie
moyennes allemandes les deux années
précédentes mais semblait indiquer que
cette artillerie étaient bien adaptées
mais après l'hiver 1941 a suivi du dégel
de 1942 il devint cruellement évident
que les pièces d'artillerie allemande
était dépassé et manqué de porter
comparé à leurs équivalents soviétique
de nouveau concept était à l'étude mais
les artilleurs déployés sur le front
devais faire quelque chose pour contrer
leurs adversaires
la solution la plus facile fut de
réutiliser au maximum le matériel
priaulx
lors de la grande offensive de 1941 les
allemands prirent une telle quantité de
canon et d'obusiers russe qui les
déplacés en grand nombre à travers
l'europe pour renforcer le mur de
l'atlantique équiper leurs unités
d'artillerie en france et en italie
les canons soviétiques furent également
engagé avec l'afrika korps dans le
désert ses artilleurs allemand utilise
des canons de 76 mm pris aux russes
comparé à la faible diversité
d'équipement engagés par les alliés sur
les différents théâtres les pièces
d'artillerie moyenne et lourdes de
l'armée allemande était trop varié ne
pouvait être ravitaillée facilement la
présence de nombreux canons pris à
l'ennemi n'arrangeait rien
la situation logistique se détériorait à
mesure qu'avançait la guerre mais le
niveau des équipes filles de
l'artillerie allemande un formidable
outil de combat tout au long de la
guerre
malgré la confusion créée par la grande
variété de canon en service
la plus grosse pièce disponible au sein
d'une division d'infanterie allemande
était un canon d'appui d'infanterie le
chevreuil infantry gay schultz 33 ans
jouait si j'ai 33 le sii g33 était une
pièce fiable et robuste capable de tirer
un obus explosifs 250 mm à une distance
de 5 km
sa munition standard était
habituellement explosive mais ils
pouvaient aussi tiré des obus fumigènes
si la situation tactique le nécessitait
une charge creuse antichar fut également
produites en 1941
mais le sii g33 était bien trop dépasser
pour être utilisés en combat anti char
le manque de vélocité des obus tirés
constituer un autre inconvénient majeur
le projectile le plus remarquable tiré
par le v6 g33 fut peut-être le style
granat heure quarante de 250 mm une
bombe de 200 livres qui étaient utilisés
pour les tirs de destruction à courte
portée contre les positions fortifiées
elle avait une charge explosive monté
sur un tube avec trois élèves de
direction elle était chargée par la
bouche du canon la tige entrant dans le
canon et les ailettes reposant le long
du frein de bouche une cartouches à
blanc spécifiques étaient utilisées pour
tirer la bombe comme une énorme grenade
à fusil après 140 m de vol le tube se
séparait de la bombe et celle ci
continuait son vol vers la cible à
l'aide de ses élèves
elles pouvaient emporter 27 kilos
d'explosifs jusqu'à une distance d'un
kilomètre
cette charge inhabituelle fut utilisée
de manière intensive sur le front russe
contre les défense bétonnée de la ligne
staline avec une efficacité dévastatrice
le rôle de l'artillerie légère était de
fournir des appuis directs aux unités de
la division le rôle de l'artillerie
moyenne est lourde et est moins précis
en général l'artillerie lourde était
prévu pour soutenir l'artillerie légère
et fournir des feux longue distance sur
des cibles spécifiques tels que les
concentrations de troupes et les
fortifications
bien que d'autres rôles lui est souvent
été assignée en 1934 commence à la
production du sfh 18 un obusier 250 mm
construit par rail metall gmbh est monté
sur un attelage construit par la fameuse
manufacture d'armes groupe
il allait devenir l'épiné dorsale de
l'artillerie moyenne de la wehrmacht
aucun document n'existe concernant le
nombre de cas n'ont produit mais il
devait être assez important car le sf
h18 rester en service jusqu'à la fin de
la guerre beaucoup furent livrés à la
finlande et à l'italie pour leur propre
armée
malgré les huit charge différentes
disponibles pour le sf h 18
sa portée maximale n'était que de 13
mille 325 m les premières expériences de
combat révélèrent tout spécialement
après 1941 que l'ennemi le surpasse est
souvent lorsque l'artillerie allemande
affrontaient les formidables canon et
obusiers russe de 152 mm
bien que des contrats étaient signés
pour développer de nouveaux concepts et
qu'une version de 170 mm étaient
introduites plus tard au cours de la
guerre les événements s'enchaînèrent
sans que le séchage 18 ne soit jamais
remplacer l'artillerie spécialisés les
unités parachutistes de montagne et de
forces spéciales posait des problèmes
aux ingénieurs militaires allemands ces
unités avaient besoin d'artillerie mais
n'avait pas les moyens de transporter de
lourdes pièces elle devait disposer
d'une gamme de tubes léger et efficace
qui pouvaient être transportées à dos
d'animal ou parachuté rapidement
réduire le poids des pièces d'artillerie
conventionnelle passe habituellement par
l'utilisation d'un alliage léger pour la
fabrication des éléments du canon et de
l'attelage mais la guerre avait raréfié
la disponibilité de tels matériaux sur
un cas non conventionnelles l'énergie
libérée par la charges propulsives
éjecte le projectile hors du canon tout
en faisant reculer ce dernier amortie
par le mécanisme de recul de l'attelage
comme les forces résultant du tir sont
considérables le mécanisme de recul doit
être très résistant et donc lourd
le canon sans recul était la solution à
ce problème
les gaz libéré par la détonation pouvait
s'échapper par une canule placé à
l'arrière de la culasse fournissant la
force appropriée pour empêcher le canon
de reculer lors du tir
la première version du canon sans recul
fut le groupe lg 1 qui entrait en
service de manière limitée au sein des
parachutistes de la luftwaffe en 1940
ils furent les premiers à l'utiliser au
combat lors du parachutage sur la crête
le lg 1 300 était une première tentative
et avait ses défauts dont l'un est l
attelage devenue trop faible pour
supporter les contraintes rigoureuses du
service actif
à force d'avoir été allégé son
remplaçant le lg 42 75 mm et est une
arme bien plus robuste avec une place
revu et corrigé et de petits trous en
métal le lg 40 possédait la plupart des
caractéristiques des canons sans recul
produit par la suite
en 1943 il fut décidé qu'un canon plus
gros était nécessaire et le 105 mm fut
mise en service
pour les unités parachutistes les canons
de 75 et de 105 mm pouvait être déployée
de plusieurs manières
l'une consistait à les parachutés en
plusieurs colis séparés dans des
containers les servants entraîné pouvait
ensuite les réassembler et les met en
batterie en moins de deux minutes
une autre méthode était de les
conditionner dans une structure
tubulaire de les charger dans un avion
de transport puis de les larguer à
l'aide de gros parachute si l'appareil
ne pouvait pas atterrir une autre
alternative consistait à charger le
canon et son tracteur léger dans un
planeur gotha géant 242,6 un
transporteur était disponible
une charge considérable pouvaient être
transportées par le messerschmitt giganc
à six moteurs que l'on peut voir sur
cette séquence prise en russie en 1943
mais malgré l'énorme taille de l'avion
le chargement n'était jamais facile
les canons de montagne un certain nombre
de canon sans recul
furent également fourni aux troupes de
montagne mais très souvent leurs
caractéristiques les rendait très
dangereux et restreignaient leur
utilisation
ce constat déboucha sur le développement
d'autres cas non conventionnelles
spécialement étudiée en terrain
montagneux
il ya un certain nombre de facteurs qui
influencent le type de canon dont les
troupes auront toujours besoin ni pro
d'artillerie pose des problèmes très
spécifiques notamment sur les questions
de mobilité de capacité à monter un
canon en haut d'un somme mais on ne peut
pas utiliser un véhicule dans ces zones
les canons doivent pouvoir être démontée
en petit sous-ensembles ceux ci
pouvaient être ainsi transportées par
des mules ils furent officiellement
dénommée chargement à quatre mules
l'autre chose que l'on voulait à tout
prix éviter en montagne était un canon
avec trop de recul car si celui ci était
trop important le canon risquait de ne
pas tenir en place sur une porte roues
au bord d'une falaise beaucoup d'efforts
et d'énergie furent investis dans le
développement de canon petit léger et
compact qui pourraient être mis en
batterie en montagne est tiré avec un
recul minimale les parachutistes avaient
besoin de canon qui pouvait être largué
ou aéro transporter ils avaient besoin
des canons sans recul certes ceux-ci
devaient être léger est manoeuvrable à
dos d'homme c'était valable aussi bien
pour les parachutistes que pour les
troupes de montagne craintes au combat
en montagne vous ne pouvez pas compter
sur les routes pour déplacer un canot à
car les routes de montagne sont étroites
et réduites et l'ennemi c'est où elle se
trouve et peut les tenir
l'artillerie de montagne devait pouvoir
se déplacer en tout terrain et les
allemands développer un matériel
le ge b36 qui était un canon de 75 mm
facilement démontable et transportable
dos d'animaux interne est remonté par
ses services plutôt que de le traîner
sur une route derrière un attelage de
chevaux ou le tracter avec un camion on
pouvait facilement le démonter en
plusieurs éléments séparés mais que ton
clapet le charger sur des mules en est
bête ou à dos d'hommes sont manoeuvrés
en tout terrain sont dépendre des routes
il devait être robuste pour supporter
les dures conditions d'utilisation
auquel il serait soumis pour ajouter un
cahier des charges déjà difficile il
devait également être capable de tirer
selon des angles extrême d'élévation et
de dépression une condition imposée par
l' environnement montagneux dans lequel
il serait utilisé une solution valable
apparu sous la forme du ge bg 18 de 75
mm une version du canon d'infanterie
standard avec un attelage allégée en
tant que canon de montagne il avait des
limites mais resta en service jusqu'à la
fin de la guerre ils pouvaient être
démontable en huit éléments séparés pour
le transport il fit preuve d'efficacité
et resta en production jusqu'en 44
le nez bouleversant quelle qu'en soit la
forme
la roquette est une arme de guerre
depuis des siècles les fusées 250 280 et
320 mm figurait parmi les plus grosses
roquettes utilisés par les allemands la
rocade de 150 mm et est la plus courante
et avait été conçu pour servir en
batterie son rôle tactique était de
saturer de grosses cibles à l'aide de
munitions explosives fumigènes ou
chimique
elle était dénommé vous granato 41 15 cm
w gr 41 et entra en service à la fin de
la roquette stabilisé par ailettes w gr
41 ans calibre 150 mm fut produite avec
toute une gamme d'options
alors que les moteurs de roquettes
étaient affectés par les températures
extrêmes des versions spécifiques furent
mises au point pour affronter les
conditions rencontrées par l'afrika
korps
une autre variante spécial dû être
produites pour supporter les grands
froids du front russe
la principale requête utilisé en union
soviétique était le double vgr 41 tiré
par le népal verseur 41 ou 15 cm mbw 41
servi par des unités spécialement formés
pour cela
l'aîné bolt roupen n'approuve aph
les bonnes verseur signifie
littéralement écran de fumée il avait
été imaginé pour répandre très
rapidement un épais écran de fumée
créée en fait les allemands réalisèrent
que se lance roquettes à six tubes rock
pouvait aussi bien des livres et des
feux de destruction très puissante avec
des projectiles explosifs que de gros
nuages de fumée fx mort par le népal
vers faire quand il entra en service en
1942 s'était fait donc utilisés comme
pièces d'artillerie pouvant tirer plus
de six projectiles sur une zone très
concentré sexe aux vins avec les
britanniques surnommaient le nebe
verseur moning mini la mini gémissante
ai appris à haïr cette arme ont raison
de son efficacité dévastatrice crêpes et
vin est un festin
il
le népal werver fut produit en une large
gamme de versions différentes
il y avait la version un tube unique
pour les parachutistes
il y avait une version à 10 tubes monté
sur un blindé chenilles et un éleveur
qui rend une requête de 360 mm il y eut
aussi un adversaire raditude 200 mm
beaucoup de ces versions furent conçus
pour tirer un projectile d'artillerie
sans avoir à s'encombrer d'un canon de
nabeul verseur était bien plus léger et
irait bien plus rapidement qu'un canon 3
car il était beaucoup plus simple
il ne fut jamais aussi précis qu'un
canons d'artillerie mais il était très
facile à mettre en oeuvre
c'était une pièce d'artillerie conçu
pour tirer les obus directement depuis
leurs casiers de stockage les serveurs
avait juste à les sortir de leur boîte
et à les mettre en place
non ce n'était pas une technique très
précise pour tirer une roquette mais
elle était très rapide et très facile
il ne fut jamais conçu comme une arme
pouvant tirer sur une tête d'épinglé
mais l'effet du bruit à l'intensité du
bombardement avait un effet terrifiant
sur le moral de l'équipe
c'était une force effrayant petit
sabater nappe de temps si court sur une
zone donnée que les troupes disait
souvent interrompt fait leurs manoeuvres
même si elle n'avait pas de blessés se
mettaient à fuir effrayé à chez foncia
le nebe verseur avait six tubes lance
roquettes montés sur un châssis après
que les roquettes étaient chargés et
connecté un boîtier électrique pour la
mise à feu les servants se mettaient à
couvert à distance et les requêtes était
mise à feu une par une pour créer une
rafale les effets d'un tir de barrage du
nebe verseur étaient dévastateurs
la déflagration d'un si grand nombre de
munitions aspirer l'air hors des poumons
d'un homme bien qu'il ne soit pas très
précis la déferlante terrifiante de ces
fusées et est souvent suffisante pour
pousser les survivants abasourdi à se
rendre
certains danger guettait les servants en
effet si la poussière soulevée par le
tir ne révélait pas la position du
lanceur les traînées de fumée créé par
les roquettes
la désignait irrémédiablement les
batteries deneb éleveurs étaient donc
des cibles de choix pour un tir de
contre batterie et les équipes
d'artilleurs d'aînés belle verte heures
devait être très rapide pour quitter
leur position si dont le tir effectué
des roquettes de plus en plus lourdes
furent utilisés par les nouvelles
troupes aient des munitions de 280 et
320 mm été tirée par une remorque à deux
roues supportant les roquettes par deux
rangées de trois superposés bien que les
feux donné belver lourd fussent très
efficace leurs marques se révélèrent
trop fragile pour suivre les panzer
division à leur vitesse de marche une
solution fut donc envisager de simple
cadre conçu pour transporter et lancer
les roquettes furent attachés sur les
flancs d'un semis chenilles et s dkfz
251 cette configuration de vins très
populaire et fut baptisé chtouka zulus
ou chtouka terrestre plus tard au cours
de la guerre des plateformes plus
sophistiqués furent fabriqués pour tirer
des roquettes plus lourde
toutes les requêtes allemandes étaient
stabilisés en vol par un effet de
vrilles
en revanche les alliés utilisé des
munitions stabilisé par des ailettes
lorsque la wehrmacht découvrit les
katiouchas russe lors de l'invasion de
l'union soviétique la stabilisation par
vri fut controversé mais comme la
production battait son plein les
concepts ne changèrent plus
le nebe werver n'était pas une arme
particulièrement sophistiqué sa
précision de tir on était améliorée que
par l'effet de vrille qui maintenait les
roquettes sur leur trajectoire peine si
nécessité une technologie sophistiquée
une course quand les russes constater
l'efficacité d'une épaule werver ils
développèrent immédiatement leur propre
lance-roquettes multiples fait et cela
donna naissance aux fameuses orgues de
staline mille-îles katioucha plus qu'à
les roquettes katioucha étaient elles
stabilisées par des ailettes
cela permettait un mécanisme de
lancement très simple avant tout cas il
n'avait pas à imprimer un effet de
rotation aux projectiles ils pouvaient
quasiment est retirée depuis inc est ils
étaient chargés sur des camions
acheminées vers le front shox le népal
vers faire d'un autre côté fut largement
amélioré les ingénieurs découvrir qu'en
montant les requêtes sur des semis
chenilles et ils obtenaient non
seulement une arme très puissante mais
aussi très mobile elle va sans dire que
autre unité avait besoin des semis
chenilles et caen et que les unités de
nabeul verseur n'obtint jamais ceci dans
les quantités dont ils avaient besoin
une fois montés sur un semi chenilles et
son disposait d'une arme très
sophistiqué qui constituait un renfort
efficace et mobile dans des combats
comme ceux du front russe
les analyses après-guerre démontrèrent
que le nez bol vert fleurs étaient en
réalité plus précis que les redoutables
orgues de staline
c'est simplement le fait que les russes
étaient est capable avec leur katusha de
déverser plus d'explosifs à un coût plus
réduit qui donnait totalement cette
impression
le siège de sébastopol en mai 1942 après
ses victoires à cacher à kharkov sur le
front russe
hitler décida de prendre sébastopol ce
port est l une des plus grandes
forteresses existantes
il était protégé par 12 batterie navale
alignant 42 canon de calibre variés
allant de 152 à 305 mm 106 mille soldats
soviétiques y stationner ainsi que des
milliers de marins affecté au canon et à
la forteresse hitler y voyait une
parfaite opportunité de démontrer
l'efficacité de son artillerie lourde
conçu au départ pour abattre la ligne
maginot désormais vaincu les allemands
installèrent 33 pièces d'artillerie de
sièges dont les calibres à l'est de 280
à 800 mm
sauf à se prend un sébastopol capturés
en 1942 par les allemands
mn et aux puces ou bien des aspects une
opération unique dans la seconde guerre
mondiale sauf en france
sebastopol était un grand port militaire
de la mer noire stratégique pour la
flotte de la mer noire est
incroyablement bien défendus par des
bunkers de béton et de très lourdes
pièces d'artillerie elle laisse moins un
mort et des dizaines dans cette
configuration la prise de sébastopol
ressembler un classique siège excellent
lequel les pièces d'artillerie joué un
rôle de premier plan
romane stein le général von manstein le
commandant allemand de l'opération
fortis avait rassemblé plus de 200
batteries d'artillerie alignons un total
de 400 pièces d'artillerie lourde
être vital pour saper les défenses
fortifiée de sébastopol crimée et laisse
aux pressions le siège dure un mois les
canons lourds furent utilisés très
habilement pendant tout ce siège contre
les défense bétonnée
il faut comprendre que certaines
défenses étaient enterrés à plus de 30
mètres sous le sol elles furent
pulvérisé par ces très grosses pièces
d'artillerie qui furent utilisés en
masse exactement comme elle devait le
faire en toute connaissance de cause
sont servis d'une manière très
concentrée
il savait vraiment ce qu'il faisait
le 3 juin 1942 le général von manstein
déversé une pluie d'obus sur les
défenseurs soviétique et les citoyens de
sébastopol plus de 750 pièces
d'artillerie prirent part aux
bombardements
quatre semaines plus tard ce qui avait
été sébastopol ressembler maintenant à
la surface de la lune
finalement au bout d'un mois de
bombardements continus sébastopol tomba
le 3 juillet
deux concepts d'armes remarquable le
mortier gamma de 420 mm et le mortier
karl de 600 mm participèrent aux tirs de
barrage
ces mortiers lourds automoteurs était
capable de réaliser sur une trajectoire
haute des tirs très efficace et
suffisamment puissant pour pénétrer du
béton épais le mortier karl fut le plus
gros des canons automoteurs engagés dans
la seconde guerre mondiale le mortier
carne pouvait également être perçu comme
un retour vers le passé
la première guerre mondiale aucun avait
vu le développement des canons sur rail
et des mortiers très lourd
ces armes étaient à l'origine du
caractère statique dans les combats du
front de l'ouest
néanmoins lorsque la série des mortiers
15 vie le jour en 1935
bref l'idée d'un mortier tirant un obus
de 600 mm de diamètre et pesant une
tonne et demie jusqu'à une distance de
10 km c'est la phrase bien
qu'impressionnante offrant autant
sembler assez anachronique une période
où l'allemagne se préparait à une série
d'actions fondé sur la mobilité et non
sur les armes de siège 9 1 1 pour leur
utilisation lors de la seconde guerre
mondiale les deux premiers canons tort
et havas a semblé en 1939 qui furent
transportés sur le front russe est
utilisée lors du bombardement de la
forteresse de bretx lykov en juillet
1941 puis lors du siège de sébastopol en
1941 et jusqu'en 1942 prend les karl
était très efficace lorsqu'il était
utilisé dans de bonnes conditions
étaient conçus comme des armes de siège
votre mis en batterie très près des
défenses sur lesquels il pouvait tirer
leurs énormes au but si destructeur non
sauf quand il pouvait détruire des
bunkers et des
ce bétonnage am le problème avec une
telle arme
c'est qu'elle nécessite de conserver la
supériorité aérienne
vous deviez avoir la capacité de la
mettre en batterie près dé défense tout
en étant sûr qu'elle n'y sera pas
vulnérable aux contre attaques
ce vaste hall 2 sa constance lors d'un
siège comme celui de sébastopol ces
conditions étaient réunies lance les
allemands furent capables d'amener leur
a retiré lourdes juste devant les
défenses de la ville vous avez la
possibilité de les orienter comme ils
voulaient à manière il était
relativement à l'abri des actions de
l'aviation soviétiques font beaucoup des
canons à sébastopol étaient pointés vers
la mer dont il était plutôt bien
protéger des tirs de contre batterie et
furent utilisés avec une efficacité
redoutable
bien que la vitesse maximale des
mortiers karl fut de 10 km heure en tout
terrain ou sur route il était trop gros
et trop fragile pour être considérées
comme réellement automoteurs la plus
grosse de toutes les pièces d'artillerie
étaient tout aussi fragile
le canon sur rail de 800 mm j'vais rue
gustave 80 cm qu'à eux
surnommé doha était positionné à 16
kilomètres de sébastopol sur un chemin
de fer spécialement installé seul a pris
deux semaines pour le mettre en place ce
n'est pas avant le troisième jour de
bombardements que son équipe de 1300
servant put enfin tirer son premier obus
au moment où ils h vers leur mission 48
obus avaient été tirés sur un ensemble
de cible qui furent toutes complètement
démolie peut-être que le succès le plus
spectaculaire fut la destruction d'un
entrepôt de munitions souterrain situé à
trente mètres sous la baie de ses verts
maya 8 confus retirer sur cette cible
qui fut complètement pulvérisée
voici un projectile de 800 mm il est
tiré par un canon à neige ferguson cela
a pris six semaines pour le mettre en
action avec une équipe de 500 hommes
sont officiers de tir était un major
général
en utilisant en masse l'artillerie
lourde de sièges sur une zone très
concentré la wehrmacht détruisit
entièrement la ville de sébastopol
quartier par quartier
l'artillerie de sièges lente à la
manoeuvre était extrêmement vulnérable
aux attaques aériennes
donc il était impératif que les
allemands conservent le contrôle des
cieux ce qu'ils firent la wehrmacht
pouvait prendre son temps pour mettre en
batterie les canons entonnant
soigneusement compte de leurs cibles
sans être harcelés par les défenseurs
les canons de sièges et de l'artillerie
conventionnelle placés autour de
sébastopol déversèrent des milliers de
tonnes de munitions sur la ville
après sébastopol alors que les alliés
reprenaient le contrôle des cieux et que
les ravitaillements se raréfiaient ses
armes de voir plus un poids qu'un atout
de tous les plans que les allemands
avaient dressé pour des armes très
lourde aucun ne se révéla aussi coûteux
que celui des super canon en termes de
matières premières de ressources
humaines et de ravitaillement en tant
qu'arme de sièges statique il n'y avait
aucun doute sur l'efficacité des
mortiers et canon sur rails
et pourtant les créateurs du 80 cm ke de
chez crew admettait que si ces engins
représentait un intérêt au plan de la
recherche
ils étaient devenus inutiles
militairement avec l'avènement de
l'aviation la guerre éclair avait rendu
les armes très lourde obsolète le siège
de leningrad le siège de sébastopol
avait duré quelques semaines celui de
leningrad allait durer 900 jours la
redoutable artillerie de la wehrmacht
avait été capable d'écraser la
forteresse portuaire de sébastopol mais
leningrad résiste à près de trois ans
peut-être que la raison principale est
que sébastopol eu la priorité sur
leningrad pour éviter que le flanc sud
de l'armée allemande ne soit exposé
alors qu'elle marchait vers le caucase
riche en pétrole les plus lourds canon
furent en priorité destiné au siège de
sébastopol au détriment de celui de
leningrad
au sud de leningrad la colline
d'observation auprès de pouchkine fut
prise en septembre 1941 la tour située à
son sommet fournissait aux observateurs
allemands une vue de premier choix sur
la ville entière qui se trouvaient à
portée de tirs des batteries de la
wehrmacht un tir de barrage continue
début talent
en deux mois entre septembre et novembre
1941 un total de 272 bombardements
d'artillerie s'abattit sur la ville sur
une durée de quatre cent trente heures
mais l'artillerie conventionnelle
allemande ne pouvait pas perforé le
béton contrairement aux canons très
lourd qui avait été à l'oeuvre à
sébastopol
beaucoup des bâtiments très bien
construit de leningrad résistèrent aux
déflagrations
bien que les forces d'hitler était en
mesure de balayer leningrad en 1941
hitler rechignait relents donné l'ordre
alors que l'implacable a retiré allemand
ne faisaient d'innombrables victimes à
leningrad la famine fut en fait la plus
importante cause de mortalité
la ville trembler sur ses fondations et
la résistance s'effondrait presque mais
les canons allemands n'était simplement
pas assez puissant pour soumettre la
ville n'ont aucune arme ne peut
remporter la victoire elle se love you
que vous pouvez tirer beaucoup de buts
sur une ville comme leningrad vous
pouvez tuer des civils par milliers
rendre tout le monde misérable mais si
vous n'attaquez pas si vous ne prenez
pas le risque de subir des pertes
importantes sans les unités d'infanterie
vous ne pouvez pas attendre d'une ville
c'est qu'elles baissent les bras et se
rendent l'armée allemande en union
soviétique avait la capacité de réduire
les noms grade de réduire sébastopol
n'avait pas les ressources pour faire
les deux en 1942 ce qui eut pour
résultat la décision de se concentrer
sur les divisions du groupement sud
auréolé du succès de sébastopol en août
1942 le général von manstein avec cinq
divisions et le train de siège de
sébastopol reçu l'ordre de remonter au
nord sur leningrad
mais l'offensive fut annulée fin
septembre
hitler était maintenant préoccupé par
l'hiver russe qui approchait et par le
fait que les canons de sièges n'aurait
pas pu être regroupées de manière
efficace contre leningrad
en octobre les renforts soviétique était
capable de jeter un nombre suffisant de
moyens militaires dans la bataille et de
repousser l'artillerie allemande cela
allait durer jusqu'en janvier 1944 mais
leningrad fut finalement sauvé